we have some 2900 guy who wants to play
without increment okay let's uh let's
give him a chance to flag me and if he
will manage then we'll just uh switch
for
for the game with increments okay
g4
and bishop f4 very very good start for
um
for those who normally play on time
knight c3 so what
what am i supposed to play here okay
let's just go g6 whatever
and let's just go bishop g7
[Music]
and castles
and reason i think you normally take and
go c5 at some point i don't know where
exactly
maybe here as well
yeah okay 96 i would guess
now maybe queen b6 or takes and queen b6
he'll probably do something like h4
there
okay i mean whatever
once again we have no no increments so
basically i cannot spend
spent all of my time here wondering
about his ideas
so now i wow knight a4 but then go queen
e5 net xc5.xc2 which i think is
acceptable but in general there should
be
a big number of lines where he allows me
some queen takes a torque when he write
queen a1 check or some little attack on
the queen side but then he just
goes for this h4 stuff and it will be
uh yeah it will be much more dangerous
for me than
than for him so he goes 92 so one of the
ideas is to
knight to a4 and then h4h5 is also there
as well
so what am i supposed to do here
i mean i can just go for something you
know completely random
and try to [ __ ] him instead like if he
goes g4 i'll just sacrifice something
and uh
look if he's fast enough you know to
convert this maybe he is actually
he takes on c5 first okay i think back
he goes knight d4 this is
um yes it's probably also smart in fact
still somehow it looks less
less of a worry to me to be honest
okay hard to survive this let's once
again let's try to do
something completely crazy just to you
know
just try to confuse him
um g4 looks normal he can also take on
f5 simply
he goes h4 then i think we'll uh we'll
just go for some attack and whatever
like he goes g4 we do something i don't
know
[Music]
maybe take on uh c3 or take on c2
shouldn't be too good for us shouldn't
be
completely lost easier i'm saying
although the last thing is less obvious
yeah queen of three queen is reason we
just go b5 and uh
once again we're trying to check mate
so there is no bishop takes b5 yeah so
he goes here then we go b4
then i think we go check and queen takes
b2
and then after rook c1 we go like e5 it
feels
okay let's go e5 feels right
so now if d takes then just d4 so he
actually has to
yeah he has to do something else exactly
can i just go bishop take g4 i probably
can
feels like ed should win somehow but i
don't see how exactly
can actually take on b4 as well that's
what i should probably do
so now it takes d4 is a sort of massive
threat
and rook b1 runs into i mean it's very
least queen takes d4
okay let's play it simple let's just
take
takes now i think he goes no he goes
here this allows bishop takes c2
rook takes it to okay let's go bishop
takes
let's play it simple just go g3
takes tanks knight d7
[Music]
our head on the clock
and two two pawns up
okay
here okay four okay seven then we just
go g4 at some point
ps3 check connect the pawn
okay let's say i don't know rook h3
lg5 king 7
p4 or v3
uh so he just he'll probably still
manage to flag results it's unpleasant
or maybe not
now he failed but at least he was
completely lost in the variance i'm sort
of proud of myself
still this was later now really nervous
for a bunch of bleeds i prefer to play
this increment